the Fukushima Daiichi nuclear plant has
six reactors that were all built in the
1970s their old designs but they were
considered pretty safe on March 11th
magnitude 9 earthquake struck off the
coast of Japan and the earthquake was
obviously bad but the tsunami it created
was what really caused trouble at the
plant right after the earthquake the
reactors went into emergency shutdown
and they needed to be cooled that job
was being done by generators and the
tsunami came in and washed around the
reactor buildings and just knocked out
all those emergency systems so without
the cooling system so the three reactors
running at the time of the quake began
to heat up plant workers scrambled to
flood them with seawater but it took too
long and it appears that the reactors
partially melted down now that means
that some of the fuel inside got out of
its normal configuration and possibly
settled at the bottom of the reactor the
process generates a lot of hydrogen gas
and that sparked a series of massive
explosions at the plant over the next
few days now after the explosions all
that mattered was keeping these reactors
very cool Japan's military and civilian
authorities did really the only thing
they could at the time which was spray
water
over the last month the water spring has
gotten a little more systematic and
damage assessments have begun it hasn't
been easy because the radiation levels
are just too high for workers to go in
and look at what's happened so what
they've had to resort to is unmanned
helicopters that can sort of provide an
aerial view of the damage to the
buildings that housed the reactors
remote cranes have also given us a look
at the tops of these buildings
but what reactor opera just really need
to do is take a look inside and to do
this they've turned to robots used by
the US military
the robots first entered units one and
three in early April what they found
wasn't particularly encouraging as we
suspected the radiation levels are still
very high so basically these reactors
are going to have to be cooled remotely
at least for the next six months or so
the cooling creates another problem
because water that goes into the core
comes out contaminated with radioactive
material it flows out through broken
pipes and cracks and it can eventually
reach the ocean the Tokyo Electric Power
Company has spent a lot of time trying
to seal the leaks one way or another
some of their techniques have been
pretty crude I mean they've just filled
this pit with concrete TEPCO is also
planning on pumping the contaminated
water into temporary storage tanks and
at least trying to process some of it to
clean it up over the next few months the
damaged reactors will also have to be
covered to prevent radiation from
spreading
TEPCO says it wants to build a temporary
cover over the site it could look like
this one that's currently being built
for Chernobyl in the Ukraine although
there it's taking well over a decade to
install up until now people on the site
have just been focused on keeping these
reactors under control it's been a
24-hour job and they haven't had much of
an opportunity to get beyond that
but ultimately they're going to have to
figure out a way to get the fuel out and
take the reactors apart at the moment
nobody seems to have an answer for how
to do this but we're likely to see more
ideas in the weeks and months ahead for
nature video I'm Jeff Brohm view
you